this is an event that you make time to
get on your count or come out year after
year why is this the event for you to
show up to give your name to has been
for 30 years so I'm here to support her
and all her hard work and what she does
to find a cure for this disease it's an
item all about good deeds giving back
your pal over on the Sony lot Alex
Trebek it's really going through
something right now just like 50,000
other people in the United States each
year this week I was diagnosed with
stage 4 pancreatic cancer now normally
the prognosis for this is not very
encouraging but I'm gonna fight this
have you been able to speak to him and
see how he's doing
yes he's hanging in there he is a strong
man and has such a will to conquer this
don't be surprised if he doesn't do it
did you know before the world knew
because we're a family I mean we've been
together for over 30 years even though
jeopardy is different than wheel we're
kind of the same right let's do a toss
up it's worth $1,000 everyone have those
devices let's go it's a phrase van a
happy 7,000 go ahead Alessandra that's a
big number this isn't it you guys just
operated 7,000 shows it's not right
correct which also means I have worn
7,000 dresses when I mean did you know
that number was coming up or what did
somebody have to tell you when you went
through your head now they told me you
know I've done this for 36 years and
they all kind of blend together it's
like wait what do you mean we're
approaching 7,000 really 7,000 jobs
you're kidding it's pretty intense 7,000
with no end in sight
his retirement even in your vocabulary
are you going to be turned into wheat
letters until you can't stop we will
enjoy watching you turn those letters
and maybe 7,000 more gowns